un salon sans coups de ciseaux depuis
des semaines
[Musique]
voilà ce que ça donne
on se pratique un peu et oui c'est très
facile de se rater pour voici quelques
conseils de survie capillaire avec
didier et ses deux modèles favoris
sa femme nathalie et son fils emilio le
mieux c'est de travailler
devant on sépare sur le dessus de la
tête
avec un père assez précisément juste
derrière l'oreille on lisse les cheveux
avec une belle tension dans les mèches
il a peut-être penché en avant aux
coupes c'est la cliente qui tourne
maintenant nous allons attaquer la
partie supérieure plus on remonte plus
c'est court évidemment tous ces cours
plus ça dégage sur le devant tout
ramener des cheveux et on termine avec
le dégrader naturelles et la coloration
alors la meilleure chose c'est de
contacter son coiffeur de l'appeler dire
qu'est ce que je fais et lui va pouvoir
vous dirigez
et pour les petits et grands garçons il
y à la méthode ciseaux souvent les gens
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils oublient le
bout de l'oreille par l'idée c'est de
venir comme ça ni recoupées avec son
peigne jeu se met le pen comme ça et de
venir faire des petits coups de ciseaux
évidemment quand les salons rouvriront
leurs portes
un jour ce ne sera plus comme avant pour
un certain temps au moins respecter une
distanciation entre les clients ça c'est
la première des choses
et puis de déchausser équipés de
personnel avec des sarraut avec des des
masques des lunettes des clients par
exemple deux sont équipés de masques
en attendant voici la méthode au rasoir
sans faire de trous dans la chevelure
je conseille fortement se vendent avec
les clippers se vendent des adaptateurs
lui que l'on a ici à peu près à deux
centimètres cubes l'oreille on se fie
mon équipe
très court en tout cas cette crise
laissera des traces
et ça dure trop longtemps il ya le
risque oui finances il ya aussi le
risque de le perdre de la clientèle
leurs clients devront aller voir plus
dans la clandestinité
c'est spécial coiffeur c'est quelqu'un
qui est très proche et en même temps
éloignés donc on se confie à cette
personne là on fait un métier
extraordinaire parce que on donne du
bonheur
mais en même temps on reçoit énormément
ça ça manque et vous êtes probablement
très nombreux à ressentir la même chose
n'est-ce pas ici frédéric arnold radio
canada montréal